والى محور المهم لاختراق السيبراني نوع من
انواع المقاومه في ايران شكلتها مجموعه
الهاكرز بلاكرورد لاختراق جدار الغموض
السميك للنظام الايراني في وقت تشهد
البلاد اضطرابات واسعه ملاحظه للحكومه ففي
الوقت الذي تشدد الصهران عمليات القمع
المتظاهرين اصبحت التسريبات والفضائح سلاح
القتال المدني الجديد قراصنه بلاكرورد
ازاحه الستاره عن معلومات دقيقه وحساسه
للغايه تتعلق بالاحتجاجات حصلوا عليها من
خلال سلسله من تسجيلات الصوت المسربه
ابرزها اعتراف لامين سر مجلس الائتلاف قوه
ثوره رضا دوريه في اجتماع مع كبار
المسؤولين الايرانيين حيث اقر بان الهجوم
على المدنيين الذي وقع في الثلاثين من
سبتمبر في مدينه زهدان عاصمه بريشستان كان
خطا فاحا حسب وصفه